sagen ich sage ich sage hallo du sagst
du sagst nichts
er sagt er sagt quatsch quatsch sie sagt
sie sagt aua ist sagt es sagt mir nichts
wir sagen wir sagen willkommen
er sagt hier sagt tschüss sie sagen sie
sagen auf wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
auf wiedersehen machen
ich mache ich mache ein video für euch
du machst du machst mit er macht macht
nichts
sie macht sie macht mich verrückt es
macht es macht alles keinen sinn
wir machen
wir machen etwas geheimes
ihr macht ihr macht uns glücklich mit
einem like sie machen
sie machen krach hören
ich höre ich höre kari und anna du hörst
du hörst mir nicht zu er hört er hört
nichts
sie hört sie hat stimmen
es hört es hört sich gut an
wir hören wir hören musik
ihr hört kari michael ihr habt mich
nicht sie hören sie hören mir nicht zu
und jetzt seid ihr dran in unsere app
ceiling könnt ihr selbst interaktiv die
konjugation von deutschen werben üben
unter anderem könnt ihr dort eure
aussprache üben und ihr könnt auf die
untertitel drauf klicken und dort
informationen zur grammatik und zu den
übersetzungen erhalten
probiert es mal aus hier geht es direkt
so sieling und hier könnt ihr sie german
abonnieren und das solltet ihr unbedingt
machen viel spaß und bis nächste woche